we always say this the the the the
independent voter the independent mind
in America is the most important voter
in America so for instance Ricky there's
zero percent chance zero you'd vote for
a Democrat yes and hell would have to
freeze exactly so and there's also let
me finish my point okay okay hold on I'm
gonna come back tomorrow Papi you get a
chance all right
um there's also a zero percent chance
that a far left BLM guy whatever would
ever vote for Donald Trump but where I
like where I'm at right now and maybe
this is my message is to be free from
the constraints of your parties a very
free feeling and to be able to kind of
be an Umpire and call balls and Strikes
and say yeah you kind of [ __ ] up here
nope you guys messed up here that so
today there's everyone wants to live in
well that's my truth that's my truth
well there's the truth and then there's
my truth so for instance you said Ricky
I don't care what you say I don't care
what evidence you show me I don't know I
never said that hold on that's not what
I said you said you hold on you said I
don't care what evidence you've ever
said that I will never not believe that
2020 election was not stolen that's
exactly what you said no that's no I I
said there's nothing you could tell me
to convince me exactly because well the
evidence is there that it was stolen
okay so my point is this no matter how
hard somebody tries if the Supreme Court
I don't give a [ __ ] that's a sick but
this is my point brother that you don't
give a [ __ ] if the 6-3 Supreme Court
came down and said by the way we've
looked at everything Joe Biden is the
winner of the 2020 election you still
wouldn't look let me tell you let me
tell you one thing because you're living
my truth
okay you gotta remember
outside of Pat and I don't want to make
judgments on anybody else I lived in
another country I've seen corruption at
its core I've lived in it so like it's
very different when you when you live in
a country where I'm going to give you an
example the one that's president right
now he ran against another guy two
elections ago and they stole it from him
and as a matter even during it's crazy
his name is uh is uh [ __ ]
um uh amlo amlo in Mexico in Mexico the
current president of Mexico during our
election said something's wrong they had
already stolen an election from him the
guy that's the guy sat there from a
different country looked at everything
he said that election is rigged when
when a person has had a stolen election
he's been running president many times
he's finally the president now sits back
and says bro that's [ __ ] from
another country from a country that I
come from we see things from a whole
different perspective that they people
think like America is like this perfect
country where everything's fine
everything's good and the government's
all intact [ __ ] there's DEA agents
and CI agents in Mexico trading the
cartels right now
so so it missed me with the whole or the
Supreme Court [ __ ] the Supreme Court
because I didn't excuse my language at
the day the reality is this I've seen
corruption at its core and when you have
DEA and CIA agents in Mexico training
the cartels you can't convince me
otherwise that's fine and then but
here's my response and we see what's
going on in Brazil right now we see
what's going on in in Mexico
this is [ __ ] America
the difference between believe to think
that okay the difference between America
and the rest of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] other countries out there
is that we believe in the peaceful
transition of power
now you can quote me on this and I'll
quote Bill Maher come 2024 whether Trump
gets blown out or not he will say that
he won the election he will claim that
it was rigged he claimed that 2016 was
rigged and he won dog so like since
Donald Trump has showed up on the scene
the democratulations
prior to that you know who had the
biggest Hillary Clinton just came out
2024 is going to be stolen she it's two
years from now I'm not even worse
already talking about Trump what are you
talking about Trump Hillary's the one
doing it right the closest election
we've ever had in our history Al Gore in
the State of Florida when George W bush
barely won Florida P.S who was the
governor of Florida at that time oh his
brother yeah Jeb Bush how about that dog
he even said you know what This Thing
Called America is bigger than me I will
say that you won the election George W
bush have it peaceful transition of
power Donald Trump does not believe in
that he does not believe in the peaceful
transition
and of course he's been echoing that
sentiment for the last five years and of
course you're going to stand let me tell
you let me tell you real quick well I
know Pat wants to continue so I'm gonna
there's the last thing I'm gonna say my
last thing I'm going to say on the
subject when I tell you that I will
never never re vote Democrat it's not
because of how I feel it's simply
because they do not align with any of my
beliefs politically tax civil uh social
in any way shape or form I they do not
align with anything that I believe in
and that's totally something to do with
feelings has everything to do with me
with me looking at facts it's the party
of slavery it's the party of Jim Crow
it's the party of the KKK and they
switch to the 1960s because it was no
longer popular to be racist and they
switched LBJ say I'm gonna have these
ends voting Democrat for 200 years
so they they just switch tactics like
what back what he was saying earlier
um this this Governor or Senator said
that it was a plantation of politics I
100 believe that's a Democrat Party so
therefore I cannot Vote or even fathom
the idea of voting for something that I
know does not align with what I believe
in and the history of the party and who
they have been and what they represent
and how they destroy everything like the
10 worst cities in the country are run
by democrats I it's so easy to be a
democrat in a in a Republican state try
being a Democrat a republican in a
Democrat state where everything they
touch goes to [ __ ] so therefore I'm I
live in it I live in the [ __ ] you know
what's great so therefore I can't live
like Ricky you said something right I
want to come to you because in a minute
but I want to say I saw a tweet the
other day uh where a 30 uh 29 year old
girl says for 28 years I've been a
Democrat
last year I just became a Republican she
says it's so funny that for 28 years
while I was a Democrat
all my Republican friends were so
patient with me yep but for one year
that I've been a republican none of my
Democratic friends even want to
associate with not tolerant it's so
funny that Republicans were so tolerant
with me Democrats were not here's the
other part Adam yeah but I gotta say
that's a [ __ ] statement because I've
lived let me go ahead let me say the
other part the other part is also the
following
when you're talking about Trump and
naive and all that other stuff bro
you believed in Russia jokes for three
years with no proof
35 000 paid by Hillary Clinton you
believed in it and tens of millions of
people believed in it because of
selective hearing because you couldn't
stand one guy no because of the media so
well but that's also form of being naive
because you chose to believe you're a
grown man it's not like you were 17
years old you want to think I'm the only
one that was naive but that's not that's
the country that's the problem that's
also a problem just like half the
country is calling for election
denialism that but but so they're naive
But but so if you want to hear something
there's a big difference
let me just say this part and then we're
going to go to the only person that has
all the experience here to talk about
this and it's right so we're going to go
to him in a minute
here's the difference
could they show one thing proof that
there was anything involved with Russia
no zero none is there proof to show that
there's been fraud in elections in the
last six years yes was it enough to flip
not yet and no that's the only
difference there is proof just not at
the level to say well we're going to
change the city or that City there is
zero proof on the Russia hoax part zero
proof on the Russia hoax part so it's
important to know
both of these sides I mean look today is
a uh is a day where Republicans can't
talk a big game but it's also a day that
Democrats can't talk a big game neither
side can talk a big game today it's
gridlock so neither site is right
neither side is wrong and neither side
both sides are also right and wrong
makes sense so both sides have something
to be right about and wrong about both
sides have something to be right and
wrong about it's not like something you
can sit there and brag about toward your
future looks bright hat click over here
and to watch the entire podcast click
here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]